good morning believe nation today's
message is have goals that motivate you
over to you Michael Phelps I had two
older sisters that I kind of looked up
to and and for them having the chance to
travel nationally and internationally
you know my Whitney was on a national
team with people I looked up to and and
you know she always come back with like
autographs and stuff and I was like I
want to do that I want to be on those
teams I want to travel the world and and
at that point I was just like you know I
want to be an Olympic gold medalist I
want to break a world record and I want
to be professional athlete and those
goals
that I thought about every single day
kept me coming week after week and year
after year until I was able to
accomplish them so green I think that
goals can be highly motivating it can
push you a little bit further then you
are comfortable going even something as
simple as saying you know hold your
breath for as long as you can and then
you time it and then maybe that's a
minute that you can hold your breath for
30 seconds then you say okay I want to
beat that 30-second mark you can do it
right even though the first time
somebody told you hold your breath for
as long as you can or reach as high as
you possibly can the next time you can
go a little bit further because you have
a benchmark and so having specific goals
can be motivating can help you get
through can help you push a little bit
harder than you're comfortable pushing I
remember when I was doing my youtube
channel my goal was to beat the other
youtuber that was at my agency and get
to a hundred thousand subscribers first
and so that motivated me daily or look
at how I was doing how he was doing
how we were competing you know who was
growing faster and ended up beating him
but that the process was fun too and I
think that's one thing that made me
missing a lot of people's goals goals
can help you push harder but you have to
make sure that the work you're doing is
inspiring is motivating it's something
that you love doing right I could have
made getting to a hundred thousand
subscribers my goal for my channel but I
didn't enjoy the process of the work
that I was doing on my channel it would
have been a food list goal I think a lot
of people set the wrong kind of goal
they set goals to try to motivate
inspire them but the work that they're
doing they're not inspired by themselves
like they don't enjoy that work and so
you have to enjoy not just the outcome
which is the goal but you have to enjoy
the process too
you get both of those then you hit the
gold mine so the question they today is
what is the most important goal that you
have for your business right now leaving
the cow is below and I will join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Yoshi me
Yoshi me thank you so much for buying
one of my books it really means a lot to
me for those of you watching if you want
to change that a shadow in the future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and email in your receipt so we can
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of ENSO